JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS
WORLD."
GETTING PLAYED FOR A CHUMP BY
DONALD TRUMP.
AFTER LITTLE ROCKET MAN BAD
MOUTHED VICE PRESIDENT PENCE AND
FAILED TO PREPARE FOR THE SUMMIT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WITH JOHN
KERRY SHOULD HAVE DONE.
HE WALKED AWAY FROM THE TABLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I DECIDED TO
TERMINATE THE PLANNED SUMMIT ON
JUNE 12.
MANY THINGS CAN HAPPEN AND A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY LIES AHEAD
POTENTIALLY.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
SETBACK FOR NORTH KOREA AND
INDEED A SETBACK FOR THE WORLD.
FAN WHEN KIM JONG-UN CHOOSES TO
ENGAGE IN CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE
AND ACTIONS, I AM WAITING.
JESSE: POTUS SENT THE NORTH
KOREAN LEADER A LETTER WHICH
READ, YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
NUCLEAR CAPABILITIES.
BUT OURS ARE SO MASSIVE AND
POWERFUL I PRAY TO GOD THEY WILL
NEVER HAVE TO BE USED.
I FELT A WONDERFUL DIALOGUE WAS
BUILDING UP BETWEEN YOU AND ME.
AND ULTIMATELY IT'S ONLY THAT
DIALOGUE THAT MATTERS.
SOME DAY I LOOK HAVE MUCH FORD
TO MEETING YOU.
IN THE MEANTIME I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE RELEASE OF HOSTAGES.
THAT WAS A BEAUTIFUL GESTURE.
INCREDIBLE LETTER AND CLASSIC
ART OF THE DEAL.
TRUMP NEVER LOCKED IN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: IF THE MEETING
HAPPENS, IT HAPPENS.
IF IT DOESN'T, WE GO ON TO THE
NEXT STEP.
THERE ARE CERTAIN CONDITIONS
THAT WE WANT.
AND I THINK WE'LL GET THOSE
CONDITIONS.
IF WE DON'T, WE'LL HAVE A
MEETING.
>> SO THE PRESIDENT GAVE UP
NOTHING WHILE THE NORTH KOREANS
DESTROYED THEIR NUCLEAR TESTING
FAT SILT, COMMITTED TO END THE
KOREAN WAR AND RELEASED AMERICAN
HOSTAGES.
TRUMP PULLS OUT AND KIM IS PUT
IN HIS PLACE.
BUT THE LEFT SEES ONLY A WIN FOR
KIM.
>> I THINK IT'S WIN FOR KIM
JONG-UN.
WHEN HE GOT THIS LETTER FROM THE
PRESIDENT SAYING NEVER MIND, HE
MUST BE HAVING A GIGGLE FIT.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS REHEARSING
THE END ZONE DANCE AND WE ARE
NOT EVEN AT THE 50 YARD LINE.
JESSE: WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SCHEDULED THE SUMMIT THE LEFT
SAID KIM WON.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT PULLED OUT,
THE LEFT SAID KIM WON.
THEY SAY KIM JONG-UN'S SISTER
WAS A BETTER DIP MATTED THAN
IVANKA.
IN THE COURSE OF THIS
PRESIDENCY, DEMOCRATS HAVE
DEFENDED HAMAS, MS-13, IRANIAN
MULLAHS, WATERBOARD TERRORISTS,
RISKY SYRIAN REFUGEES AND
ANTIFA.
TRUMP'S SUCCESS HAS BOXED
DEMOCRATS INTO SUCH RADICAL
POSITIONS THEY ARE BECOMING
POLITICALLY IRRATIONAL.
NOW THE KOREANS SIGNALING THEY
WANT THE MEETING BACK ON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
IT WAS A NICE STATEMENT THEY PUT
OUT.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IT COULD BE THE 12th.
WE ARE TALKING TO THEM NOW.
WE ARE GOING SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
JESSE: CLEARLY THE NORTH KOREANS